hello everybody we just hit 90,000
subscribers today man thank you so much
I'm gonna try to keep this short and
sweet because you guys know that I have
a tendency to ramble about things that
don't really matter but what does matter
is that you guys have been so amazingly
supportive of me and my goals and I
can't you know I don't thank you enough
I really don't I haven't done as many
logs as I have in the past that's
because I've been kind of focused on
making the actual game videos but if you
guys in this channel are incredibly
important to me like this is this is
I've care more about this channel than a
habit of anything that I've done in my
entire life seriously I get up out of
the morning I still like I said a long
time ago and be like way way way back
when that it was this channel is the
reason why I get up in the morning and
the reason why I lose sleep at night
because if I'm not doing anything or
talking to people and I spend a lot more
time talking to people and I'm happy
about that
I'm thinking about the channel almost 24
hours a day and I check up on the
statistics and I check up the things and
it's amazing because we're getting over
a thousand subscribers a day I mean just
yesterday I think we got 1500 in one day
for a channel my side that's ridiculous
and it's like it's all thanks to you
guys seriously you guys and gals out
there I say guys but no I mean guys
girls and honestly it means so much to
know that you guys have got my back
because I said a long time ago not a
long time go back in July I think I've
been doing this for longer than I have
but I said that I wanted to make a
difference in the world by this time
next year I want my channel to be big
enough to make an impact on the gaming
community as a whole that's what I want
that's what I want for you guys and I
always want to make sure that I do that
every day and you guys need to call me
out on that if I don't meet up to the
expectations that you guys are you know
getting from me and the promises that I
made a long time ago if I'm not keeping
them you need to call me out on that
because if I don't follow through then
I'm doing this for the wrong reasons and
the right reasons are to try to build a
community that can help people in the
world and bring people together over a
common goal and that's gaming gaming is
awesome because its global it's
worldwide and everyone can get together
for a purpose that's just can do more
you know it can do more and that's why
I'm announcing next weekend next weekend
I believe it's the sixth or the seventh
I'm not sure next Saturday not this
Saturday next Saturday is our next
charity livestream I'm gonna try to do
them at the beginning of every single
month I don't know what charity just yet
but I will announce closer to the day
but it will be another good one maybe
I'll go back to child's play it's been a
while since I did a child's play charity
but either way I hope you all join me
then but that's next week what's what's
important now is that you guys
understand that I am unbelievably
grateful for the opportunities that you
have given me I've eaten so many cool
people through this like a lot of people
out there who have joined my subscribe
join my channel just recently I'm a
subscribed recently I'm afraid that
they're just gonna see me as a character
you know I'm they watch a video and they
see me react and scream and you know be
silly and they may see like something
like the king of the squirrels video and
they may think that oh he's just you
know that's just due he's being on
camera and I'd like to think that this
channel is representative of my
personality because my personality is
loud and
random and very silly at times but also
it gets very serious because I can take
things seriously when they need to be
because I know this is for entertainment
but at the same time I have a
responsibility to make sure that we do
the right things with this channel
that's why I do the charity livestreams
in I've come from a rough rough rough
couple of years his past few years and
you guys know I've said all about it but
I've never been you know as happy to do
what I'm doing as I have today and I
have only you all out there to thank for
that you have quite literally changed my
life and my original goal for a hundred
thousand subscribers was by June of this
year and we're gonna hit it next week so
that's that that's just absolutely
incredible in it I can't you know I feel
so honored to be just this person in
front of a camera that so many people
because I used to think that 5000 people
was just an unimaginably huge number I
used to think a couple hundred people
was ridiculous now that that's
approaching a six-figure sum and it's at
ninety thousand right now that that's
unbelievable
so thank you guys from the bottom of my
heart you know I love you guys not like
that not like that no seriously I love
you guys to death I would do anything
for this channel and I would do anything
to make sure that what we're building
here last and I know it's not gonna last
forever but last for something important
and okay apparently short and sweet at
five minutes fudge alright so thank you
guys so much I it's just I don't have
enough time to
you guys how much you mean to me and how
about this channel need to be and what
we're doing means to me
but hopefully each day by day maybe I'll
try to do a few more V logs here and
there because all of this all this is so
important just being able to believe in
your okay alright I'll ramble I know I'm
about to ramble on to another two minute
thing so I'm going to cut it off
yourself thank you all so much for
watching thank you for 90,000
subscribers please join me next weekend
next Saturday for the charity livestream
that we got going on just thank you guys
every each and every one of you thank
you and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye